[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24 depuis le 24 février à la
surprise générale l'ukraine résiste à la
russie sur le terrain bien sûr mais
aussi dans la sphère digitale
l'ukraine n'a non seulement pas été
coupée du monde mais elle a même été on
peut le dire capable de gagner cette
guerre digital l'architecte on est le
ministère de la transformation numérique
est notre invité aujourd'hui depuis kiev
et son vice ministre georges dubinsky
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
merci à vous pour cette invitation je
suis ravi de vous envoyer un bon jour de
cuivre de l'ukraine alors comment est ce
que on peut expliquer que la russie avec
toute sa puissance on l'a vu à l'oeuvre
dans des campagnes électorales aux états
unis n'a pas réussi à mettre hors d'état
de nuire les réseaux de
télécommunication l'infrastructure
numérique de l'ukraine
nous nous sommes préparés
pour cette guerre
et nous comptons en fait le début de
cette guerre non pas le 24 février mais
nous comptons
depuis 2014 où nous avions déjà cet état
de préparation
et nous avons déjà prévu que la russie
va essayer de déstabiliser notre
infrastructure numérique et je peux vous
rappeler que
le cren a déjà subi et 4,1 tactilos
attaque et sur les infrastructures
énergétiques il y avait un attaque
virale virus petya
et donc nous avons déjà eu une
expérience
auparavant qui a permis de mettre en
place un système de protection de notre
système informatique et 6es et ses
systèmes numériques et nous avons élargi
oc l'accès de notre population de nos
citoyens à internet à haut débit mais
nous avons compris qu'il faut prévoir
d'autres alternatives à la fibre et aux
réseaux mobiles et donc nous avons
recherché activement ces alternatives et
si vous voulez savoir les détails nous
notre ministre monsieur fedorov pris
attache avec elon masque pour lui
demander des paraboles starlink et nous
avons reçu une réponse très très
réactive
c'est les systèmes les paras paul
starling ont permis de créer une
infrastructure critique de protection
nous avons pu déployer très très vite
plus de 10000 terminons
starlink et et pour assurer le lien
permanent à l'internet pour notre
infrastructure critique pour les
hôpitaux et même pour les zones qui
étaient sous l'occupation russe auto les
autres moyens de communication ont été
endommagés nous avons pu très vite grâce
à starling rétablir le lien et les
communications via internet donc c'était
un moyen très efficace de s'opposer
aux attaques ir tous les dommages que
les russes ont emporté à nos
infrastructures
donc vous dites que starling alors c'est
vrai qu'on en a beaucoup parlé avec le
rôle de l homme a semé
on avait peut-être l'impression que
c'était peut-être juste un gadget là ce
que vous dites c'est que ça a été une
clé pour votre défense numérique cet
apport finalement du secteur privé
en effet on peut dire à ce jour que ces
terminaux ces paraboles starlink on
devenu un moment qui a sécurisé notre
infrastructure critique il c'est vrai et
c'est révéler vraiment
critique quand la russie
attaquer
attaquer tout notre infrastructure
par exemple les premiers jours de les
premiers jours de guerre notre service
de stockage de serre notre serveur
principal de protection des registres
d'état a été attaqué par un missile à
missile qui a frappé et donc nous avons
pu grâce à grâce à des porcs physique
des serveurs et aussi grâce à ces
paraboles de protéger l'infrastructure
critique
encore lorsque donc lorsque les
infrastructures physiques ont été
endommagés les sterling a été un relais
très important et nous avons intégré
starling très rapidement dans notre
système de télécommunication ce qui
permet de dire de témoigner de sa
flexibilité d'accord le commandant
cybers de l'armée américaine a reconnu
récemment avoir mené une série
d'opérations en réponse à l'invasion
russes et en réponse l'ambassadeur russe
en charge des questions numériques andré
cools croûte chic a dénoncé une cyber
agression déclenchée par les états unis
qui utiliserait je le cite le régime
zelensky et son armée informatique est
ce que en effet les états unis à travers
vous mène une sorte de guerre numérique
avec la russie
ces allégations russes sont absolument
inacceptables parce que le monde entier
sait que
que c'est la russie qui a été à
l'origine des attaques
par exemple lé virus pbs cosy bio c'est
que c'était des unités russes en liaison
avec le service des renseignements
militaires et qui ont mené bien avant
l'agression
l'agression donc en ukraine ces attaques
et les systèmes financiers mondiaux ont
été attaqués et le dommage a été causée
de 10 milliards de dollars donc on peut
dire que c'est vraiment des allégations
à l'envers c'est la neige c'est la
russie qui est à l'origine de ces
agressions et 10 et des attaques
et mais je peux effectivement qu'ont
confirmé que dans le domaine de la cyber
protection une coopération avec les
états unis nous avons une est donc un
projet de coopération cyber dialogue
dont un tout un axe de coopération avec
les principales puissances numérique et
comment mieux protéger nos systèmes
informatiques et numériques et en ce qui
concerne l'alarmé c'est le commandement
c'est bien en effet nous avons une armée
mais ce sont des volontaires
quand ils se sont volontairement engagé
dans les troupes de l'armée haïti
l'armée cyber
île
c'est ces volontaires en fonction de
leurs capacités de
apportent leur obole au système de de
résistance de résistance est ce qu'on
peut appeler notre réponse asymétrique
c'est un sorte de mouvement des
maquisards
cybernétique mais est-ce que cela inclut
aussi justement peut-être pour frapper
entre guillemets en tout cas dans le
cyber la russie des actions en russie ou
contre la russie directement justement
pour résister à l'agression
la question des attaques contre les
sites russes et peuvent être considérées
dans quelle mesure ces sites ont été
utilisés comme arme contre l'ukraine il
cède à partir de là on peut qualifier
c'est une attaque défensive ou au
contraire offensive par exemple si les
les
la russie a vraiment parti dans une
attaque d'une violence contre les sites
civils contre la population civile et
bien elle a ça ça ça nous permet aussi
de répondre de manière symétrique bien
entendu mais pour cibler par exemple les
sites de propagande russe et qui
divulgue beaucoup des forces nouvelles
filles news et beaucoup de zinfos
fausses informations
il est donc
là oui nous pouvons cibler ce type de
sites et de propagande pour le
pour les mettre à mal et notre
résistance cyber a déjà essayé donc
cibler ce s'il de ressources
mais je rappelle encore une fois avant l
invasion russe à la veille de 24 février
c'était même 24 janvier donc un mois
avant l'ukraine a subi deux attaques
sans précédent
d'une grande envergure de didonne
attaque et je vous dis pour préparer une
telle attaque le coût de préparation se
chiffre à 1 me à 1 milliard de dollars
un milliard de dollars et donc ces
attaques ont visé les sites
gouvernementaux
et les différents sites des communautés
territoriales
donc cette guerre informatique de la
russie elle a commencé bien avant le 24
février
et donc c'est effectivement maintenant
pour nous et c'est la défendre nos
frontières numérique y compris non
seulement territoriales mais aussi
numérique dernière question monsieur
double ce qui on en a entendu beaucoup
d'appels de votre ministre par rapport
aux géants de la de l'ateq évidemment on
a parlé de elon musk mais aussi ce que
ces géants coupe les liens avec la
russie ça a été long à se mettre en
place est ce que vous êtes désormais
satisfaits ou y at il toujours des
géants du numérique qui rechignent à
sanctionner la russie que vous aimeriez
apprendre voir prendre des mesures
supplémentaires
les géants de numérique de la tec se
retire du marché non pas en suivant
notre appel mais aussi parce qu'ils se
rendent bien compte que cette guerre ce
n'est pas seulement la guerre de russie
en ukraine mais c'est un conflit de
civilisations dont lequel différentes
valeurs s'opposent et donc le fait de se
comporter aujourd'hui à la russe comme
au moyen-age ce n'est pas acceptable au
21ème siècle
donc c'est pour ça que ce sont les
valeurs de démocratie de liberté que le
crel de fonds
cette bataille donc c'est un sens c'est
aussi le socle des valeurs auxquelles
s'appuient les géants de la tête et
c'est pour ça c'est le décision émanant
de leur propre et soeurs de sorte de
sortir du marché russe et c'était le
choix de la russie de s'enfermer dans le
moyen-age et nous sommes d'ailleurs très
reconnaissant avec
avec ces géants de la tête qui nous
aident beaucoup nous sommes très
reconnaissants je voudrais aussi
remercier les gouvernements avec qui
nous comprend beaucoup et en particulier
je voudrais saisir cette opportunité
pour remercier au gouvernement français
ce qui est interdite à deux numérique et
qu'elle est cédric est qui
qui nous a beaucoup aidés et consulté et
concernant l'achat des équipements
nécessaires et concernant la protection
des régistres d'état critique
donc nous avons été obligés de migrer
beaucoup faire migrer beaucoup de
serveurs et cette expertise a été très
précieuse pour nous
donc
le monde le monde n'accepte pas
n'accepte pas ce comportement russie ni
sur le plan militaire ni sur le plan
cybernétique et je pense que la
résistance et sur le plan de la
civilisation
georges binz qui merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu aux questions de france 24
depuis kiev et merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cet entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]